Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
I had a chance to see the Blue Beetle
movie, so this will be my review video.
The very first new character
in James Gunn's rebooted DC movies.
I know there's lots of questions
about that.
He did publicly clarify
how it's going to work.
So I'll explain that during the video,
since
we have a bunch of DC movies this year
and most of them will not be Canon
pretty soon, Blue
Beetle is the one exception to that.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'm doing the giveaway for movie
tickets to.
All you have to do to Enter
is be a subscriber and just let me know
where else you want to see Blue Beetle
in the upcoming DC movies and series
we already know a couple places where he's
supposed to show up in the future.
I'll talk about that in my full breakdown.
Easter
Eggs videos was I'll post later this week
like my Post-Credits scene video.
There is a post-credits scene,
so be sure to stay after the credits
and please
don't post spoilers on this video.
as the me posting this video.
It hasn't come out everywhere yet.
Don't worry, I will post full breakdown
extras, all that stuff later this week.
We'll talk about all that stuff.
There is plenty to talk about.
My only real exposure
to the Blue Beetle character on screen
before this was the young justice
in the Smallville series.
I did read most of his original comics
when the character debuted
during Infinite Crisis
back in the mid 2000.
So most of my memory of the character
is from that era.
of all the TV show
versions of the character,
overall, I'd say Young Justice
is the superior version of Blue Beetle.
Just amongst that in Smallville.
If you haven't seen either versions,
I would recommend checking them out.
There was a brief period where they tried
to develop a Blue Beetle TV series
with a similar version of the character,
but it was back with Smallville
era level technology.
pretty easy to see why
they decided not to do it
just because it would have been
so expensive.
With that level of technology.
this new blue beetle is a very easy
upgrade for the live action
versions of the character.
Like it is a huge step up
from what you saw during Smallville
Originally,
the movie was greenlit with the intention
that it would be a small budget streaming
movie that they would release on HBO.
Max Kind of like the Batgirl movie.
So this will start to sound familiar
the movie has a very interesting history.
Like a lot of DC movies
that are coming out this year,
you have to remember that
this is back in the ancient before times
of just two years ago
when AT&T still owned Warner Brothers.
they and other streamers like Disney
Plus were developing movies
just meant for streaming,
not for theaters.
So they were spending way less money on it
going into it.
Blue Beetle had always been planned
to be a smaller type of movie
compared to something like The Flash,
which reportedly they almost spent
about half a billion dollars
trying to make and reshoot and market blue
Beetle costs like a fraction
like a tiny fraction of that
The movie survived a couple
big regime changes at Warner
Brothers in DC, like all the DC movies
this year.
infamously Warner Brothers separated
from AT&T, then merged with Discovery.
They started canceling stuff left
and right to save money.
That's
what happened to the Bad Girl movie.
but on the flip side of that, this is a
huge win for the Blue Beetle movie.
Early on especially,
they felt like the Blue
Beetle movie was so strong that it went
in the complete opposite direction
of something like Batgirl instead of
canning the whole movie after it was shot,
they upgraded it
to a full theatrical release,
gave it like a little bit more money,
it a little bit more marketing behind it
to boot instead of relegating it
to the no longer and Snyder verse
of DCU movies, even though originally
it was supposed to be canon to the DCU
without having to make any huge changes
or delete a bunch of it.
James Gunn said that he was making Blue
Beetle canon to his new DCU
rebooted movies like Yes,
you will see this character show up
with other future characters
that I'm introducing in upcoming movies.
There are a couple of minor points
in the movie, like
there are some Man of Steel references
to Henry CAVILL'S Superman
and Zack Snyder references
that you'll recognize pretty easily,
even though technically it is supposed
to be canon to James Gunn's DCU.
that'll throw a couple of people off.
But I didn't think it was too out of place
during the movie.
The director just claimed
that he was a huge Zack Snyder fan, Ben.
Zack Snyder, very publicly supported
the movie, said he was bringing his entire
family, was really excited to see it.
So it's actually a pretty cool situation.
very different story from what you saw
when the Flash movie was coming out.
So of all the DC movies this year,
it just feels like Blue Beetle
got the biggest upgrade of any DC
project ever and is getting way more
push behind it than something like
The Flash, which they spent hundreds
of millions of dollars trying to market
and after seeing the movie.
I feel like they made the right call
with Blue Beetle.
Even if you weren't a huge fan
or aware of the character
before Young Justice or Smallville
or you're just learning about him now,
the movie succeeds on pretty much
every front where the flash movie failed.
really important to remember, though,
that it's designed to be a much smaller
type of movie.
It just succeeds on every front
that it attempted.
they only spent about $120 million
making it, which for superhero movies
is like the money you find in your couch
cushions.
It didn't have any of the weird
logic errors that the Flash movie did
or any like really big
missing character arcs
that it feels like
they just deleted out of the movie.
and even when the movie gets a little too
silly, it never strays into the territory
of like the Ezra miller flash
level weirdness,
like the really strange CGI choices
they made with the Speed Force Blue
Beetle, CGI, huge upgrade from Smallville.
Obviously pretty easy for them to do that.
remember the Smallville version
was more than ten years ago.
it doesn't suffer from that weird Ezra
miller swim running effect kind of thing.
Like they're not doubling down
on any weird stuff from previous movies.
and the movie is canon to the upcoming
DC movies like Superman Legacy, would
I think was one of the biggest strikes
in its favor
because I think a lot of people
who even were familiar with Ezra miller
or any of the drama around the Flash movie
just weren't as excited about it
because they knew that the Flash movie
wasn't going to be a thing.
In another year or so.
let James Gunn and DC basically came out
and said there was no flash stuff
happening in the first era of his DC
movies.
really easy
way to get people to avoid your movie.
If you tell them that it's completely
irrelevant in the next couple of months.
thankfully Blue Beetle
has none of those issues.
there were a few minor
things in the movie,
few minor issues
that I had I'll talk about in a second.
But for instance,
if you're not a big blue beetle fan
or you're not a big fan of the actors
in the movie,
this isn't going to completely
turn you around.
but Zola was great.
Is Jamie Raya, as most of you
remember him from Cobra Kai?
He's great on that series.
I think he did a better job in
the movie is Jaime Ray
is he definitely captures
the energy, the comic book.
you will be excited to see what he's going
to be like crossing
over with these upcoming characters
like Booster Gold, Superman,
the other Justice League characters
when they're eventually introduced.
the way I think of him
is kind of like a Tom Holland Spider-Man
type of character during Civil War,
like a younger version of the character.
Even though in this movie, Jaime Ray,
his character is a little bit older
he's like post-college.
he's got the same type of energy
that Tom Holland's Spider-Man had
when he was first introduced to the MCU.
one of the other major wins of the movie
that it has over the Flash is
his relationships with his family
are way more prominent,
even though The Flash's mother
was like the whole reason for Flashpoint
during that movie, during blue beetle,
his actual family are much
bigger characters
throughout the entire movie,
not just like the beginning
in the end of the movie.
They're not just minor plot points.
each of his family
members plays a huge role,
very clearly definable role in the movie.
His grandma, Nina,
is probably one of the standouts for that.
George Lopez is either like a love it
or hate it kind of situation.
If you like his type of comedy, his vibe
before this, you'll enjoy his character.
He gets pretty silly.
But if you did not like him before this,
the movie
isn't going to turn you around on him
or anything like that.
he almost gets a little too silly
at times.
He's sort of like the crazy
conspiracy type of character.
But he does
have a great relationship with Jaime.
Ray is in the film.
So he was great
during those parts of the movie.
Bruno was great as Jenny cause she's
playing Ted Cord's daughter in the film.
Most of you who are Blue Beetle
comic book fans, I'll talk
more about him in my full Breakdown
and Easter Eggs video later this week.
She is one of the big comic
book changes that the movie makes.
But they did a good job of
setting her character up
for some really interesting
story upgrades in potential sequels
or future appearances.
They're waiting to see how the movie does
financially at the box office
like you would expect
before they greenlight a sequel.
there's always a chance that they don't do
more Blue Beetle solo movies.
If that happens,
they would probably just see
the characters crossover in future movies
from other characters
in series like the Booster Gold Series
related movies to that stuff.
Bruna and Zola
had great chemistry together,
so I'm interested to see where they take
the two of them together in the future.
If you're a big Dragon Ball
fan, the best comparison I could make is
she's kind of like a bulma in the movie,
like the tech wizard that has access
to all the cool toys.
most of you who watched Power Rangers
at some point the last 20 years.
Remember Becky G?
She's playing the voice of codger
dog, the Blue Beetle scarab itself.
She was a power Ranger herself as well.
There's a bit of Power Rangers
energy in this.
The director made some Cayman writers
references on his Instagram to Most people
saw the anime influences
when the first trailer debuted.
she's playing kind of like a Jarvis
or a Friday type of role
to make a marvel comparison.
The Iron Man movies I didn't think her
character was quite as good as Jarvis, but
there's a lot of room for them to improve
that when they bring the character back.
Susan Sarandon did an okay job
as the main villain.
Victoria Court
I was a little surprised
to see her in the movie,
but she's always pretty solid
in most of her appearances.
Harvey Green was fun.
As her scientist henchmen,
you probably remember him
from what we do in the shadows,
do their obvious villain.
The movie was car parks.
He had a slightly better character
arc than Victoria Coors,
or at least more clearly defined
use more of the tragic villain.
They wanted his story
to be like a dark parallel for
Hi May memories
like this is what could happen to you
if you didn't have
such strong relationships
with your family in them around you.
seriously Vin Diesel would be proud
of how important family is to this movie.
It's all about family.
The director did a good job
of adapting the energy of the comic book
with a few minor backstory changes,
like he definitely understood
the assignment
meant to be a much smaller movie,
but you want all the character arcs,
especially the supporting characters,
to shine through
They also did a good job of setting up
for potential sequels, feature crossovers
with other DC characters.
So there's a lot of interesting ideas
that they bring up during the movie,
but not things like The Flash movie
was like a big plot point that sets up
absolutely nothing that they're ever
intending on paying off most of my minor
issues with the movie that just gets
a little too silly at times.
It definitely feels like
it could have been a big budget TV show
if they'd wanted, but a really good TV
show compared to something
like Secret Invasion, for instance,
which cost Marvel over $200 million.
I can't believe the secret invasion costs
more than a lot of giant Marvel movies.
Blue beetle costs almost like half that
and succeeds on all fronts
where secret invasion failed.
just to compare it to like all the other
comic book superhero movies
that are coming out this summer. It's
similar types of movies.
I say it's not quite as good as Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles
or Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse
Guardians of the Galaxy three.
those three are like the standout est here
comic book movies of this year.
Blue Beetle is still really solid.
Definitely better than the Flash.
I haven't seen Aquaman two yet,
so I can't really compare it to that.
still think that Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse in Guardians
three will go down as the best
comic book movies of the year, though
right after that
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Then right after that,
probably Blue Beetle.
when you have a chance
to see the movie, post your reactions
in the comments, remember, no spoilers.
My Post-Credits Scene Video Full Breakdown
Easter Eggs will post late this week,
so don't wait to go see the movie
and remember stay after the credits.
big reminder, there's a bunch of stuff
coming up next week to a soak episode.
Start. I'll be doing full videos for that.
Be sure to enable others for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
all the DC HBO series will start next year
too, like the Batman HBO series,
I'll start doing more videos for that
when they start releasing more trailers,
but click here for my brand new Doctor
Strange three video
and click here for all my new Deadpool
3 videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!